active America free is going to go up
against Batman and Superman you may have
if you go plans to suitabie up the ante
and do you think you might see another
Avenger celebrity boxing match that's
what yeah we're working right now no I
don't know I think who said this best
that you know when two two cars are
speeding at each other one of them has
got a veer out of what out of the way at
some point so hey oh yeah
the listen I think you know Marvel
marvel I think announce that date
originally it was a if you go back
historically and look at it Marvel and I
think Sony had been trading off and that
may date for a long time and I think
when Warner Brothers decided to move
that film they moved it to the may date
so you know I can see where Kevin said
one I'm not moving off that well so yeah
it's right over there
so I don't think there'll be anything to
up the ante other than that you know
hopefully we make a great movie and
everybody's very excited to see it on
was it may 5th or may 6th and I mean
that's the truth is anybody up anybody
up here is just all we can do is make a
you know focus on making the best movie
we can make and when and how it gets
released is yeah there's other forces
involved in that in other words in other
words pump stuff up to give me yeah DC
where you have interesting bad guys we
got Chris Evans baby deal with dad
[Laughter]
you